okay all right so I want to talk about a
model of local computation algorithm and
I want to give a sense of the types of
results we got within this model so so
let's start with the context the context
is ok you have huge data you don't have
time to read all the data but you need
to somehow compute some parameter of
this data ok but not only is your input
extremely large but also your output
might be extremely large ok so the what
I want to talk about today is the
setting when you have this large output
you'll need to compute but you don't
actually need the whole output you just
need a piece of it ok and if you only
need a piece of the output do you
actually have to compute the whole thing
and then just look at the piece that you
need or is there some way that you can
just compute what you need ok so in fact
even more so the question is whether you
can not even look at all of the input ok
so we're interested in sub linear time
algorithms algorithms who's running time
is very small compared to the size of
the input and very small compared to the
size of the output as well ok so that's
what we're going to look at I'd like to
give some examples and these are these
are examples that fit within the
paradigm that I'm going to be discussing
today that have been around for a long
time so for example in coding theory
they had locally decodable codes where
the input you think of as an encoding of
a large message the output of the
decoding algorithm is the original large
message but maybe you don't actually
need I mean so this is huge this is huge
but maybe you don't need to actually you
don't maybe you don't need the whole
original message maybe you just want to
know what's the ice bit ok or you know a
few of the bits of the original are such
message now the question is do you need
to decode the whole message in order to
just get the pieces that you need ok it
turns out you don't you know you can
design really good codes for which very
few queries are needed in order to
compute the answer ok so this is like
you know a cool of the theory community
great there's been a lot of work that's
just a couple of citations there's a
million citations to put up there
okay similar thing was done for
decompression so here the input is the
compression of a large piece of data the
output is of the decompression algorithm
is the original large data but maybe you
don't want you know you want to make
some computation on the original data
you don't need to know the whole data
you just you need certain pieces maybe
you needed to do binary search to see if
you know dick carp is in your list for
example so you just need to answer
queries of the type what is the ice bit
do you need to actually decompress the
whole input and the answer is well
depending on the compression scheme but
basically know there are compression
schemes which compress well at least as
compared to various you know standard
compression schemes and there are very
few queries to answer these site types
of questions okay so just I want to just
mention a quest I'm in an application
maybe you have like a gene bank it's
growing information it's huge you don't
want to recompress every time you added
a few more genes to your gene bank and
these sequences are highly redundant
both within the DNA sequence and also
between people's DNA sequences so it's a
great place for online compression but
you know if you want to run some
bioinformatics algorithm you don't want
to decompress the whole thing okay so
that's an example um now let me turn to
yet a different a third scenario where
you might want what we call local
algorithms and this is in graph
partitioning and page rank here for
example you might have a huge graph you
know you know the net the facebook graph
or something like that and you want to
find community so you want to find a
good cut near a certain node V where the
run time depends only on the size of the
small side of the cut or you might want
to estimate the page rank of V or you
may want to do some sort of spam
detection or community detection so
there's been a number of works on these
sorts of models as well and perhaps also
as a methodology for denoising data here
you have in your given an input which
should have some useful property but
it's been slightly corrupted and no
longer has this property
so you would like to you would like to
correct your input so it's close to the
original input but also has this sort of
expected property but you'd like to also
do it in such a way that the original
values are quickly accessible okay so
this is something I realize now I forgot
to fix so you're gonna have to bear with
me a slight bug in my powerpoint thing
okay so but let's say this is your
original data okay yeah this is this is
your original data okay so this is um so
this is your original data uh but the
thing was supposed to be monotone okay
so some of these got corrupted like
these guys maybe this one too so what
you'd like to do okay you'd like to give
random access to the real values of the
list or at least some possible real
values of the list okay so you'd like to
this is not supposed to be there and so
you'd like to sort of correct the list
to something like that okay but let me
just point out that it's not so clear
like if if you're asked for random
access you're trying to figure out how
to fix this you need to say okay do I
need to just fix it so it's between
these two or do I need to go further out
and look at whether it's between these
two and then the question is how far how
much farther out do I need to go in
order to determine this it turns out
this is a problem that can be solved
actually in logarithmic time okay so
it's not it's not an obvious algorithm
although it may look obvious from this
example it's actually not so obvious and
okay and so you can fix this in such a
way that it provides local access in
logarithmic time you can correct the you
can correct each point of the data and
and in the end you'll return according
to some monotone function so so it's so
when I say it's a paradigm for
correcting data I mean you know what
would be the correct data it's not
really clear you're told that this thing
was supposed to be monotone you see that
it's not so maybe a natural thing to do
would be to correct to the closest
monotone function or to a close monotone
function and given that this is
something that is doable okay so I'm not
sure if that's what you would consider
denoising the data but if this ever
turned out to be what you would
sidered denoising the data you can do it
okay that's I think my main point here
you here it's Hamming distance but if
you want to turn it into l1 distance I
think you can actually do better than
logarithmic or maybe that's an open
question so a okay so what does this say
that you can also
you can check if a list is closed too
monotone in logarithmic time it in
closing Hamming distance so this result
is actually I would say the check that a
listed closes first of all it came at
least 10 years earlier than this result
so and I would say it's easier so the
property testing like testing the
property of whether a list is closed too
monotone is something that can be done
in logarithmic time as well um that was
one of the first property testers and I
would say that's easier so similar
authors it's um they related in since I
I would say not always or that the
technique is related but the proof in
you use this algorithm to do the testing
even though the testing is easier can
you actually use this algorithm to do
the test me that yes and that and
actually dead you can do a stronger form
of testing I so yes you can use it to do
testing and you can even do a stronger
form of testing I would say that the
algorithm used to is inspired by but but
not as clear-cut as the testing
algorithm and that is because it does do
something stronger okay so there's a
bunch of properties that can be
reconstructed monotonicity Lipschitz
conditions convexity in graphs you can
do Corrections you can turn a graph that
may have had some edges broken but you
can turn it back into an expander graph
you can turn graphs into like graphs
that aren't quite connected you can make
them connected by adding just a few
edges in a local manner you don't have
to look at the whole graph in order to
do this K connectivity small diameter so
what I want to talk about now is maybe
let's suggest a good unifying model
which sort of gets at all these
different types of problems so here
you've got some input X and this is
actually written down okay and now in
your head I mean not maybe unfortunately
maybe not in my head but somebody's head
there's an output Y and this
what the algorithm wants to compute okay
but it actually just needs pieces of it
so now we have this thing which will
call the local computation algorithm and
it gets inputs like I 1 I 2 I 3 and it's
supposed to answer with what's the
output of y at location I 1 I 2 I 3 okay
so it's supposed it's sort of an online
thing that's you're giving it queries
and it's outputting answers ok and this
guy this LC I can make queries random
access queries to the input wherever you
want and you know nobody can pray this
because it's not there it's enough it's
not written but this is what we're
trying to compute but you could you
could query the input you don't have
time to read the whole thing but you can
look at any location in the input that
you'd like ok so I just want it just to
make this more concrete let's use a
running example of maximal independent
set and just so that we're all on the
same page let's define maximal
independent set you're giving a sparse
undirected graph the dig I'm going to
assume that the degree is it most d so
deep and that's and we're also going to
assume the D is a constant for today
although it doesn't have to be and in an
independent set is a subset of the knows
where no two are connected by an edge ok
so all these red guys there are no edges
between red guys and maximal means that
you can't add another you can't add
another node to this red set without
violating the independence ok so if I
add any other node then I'm not going to
have this property where there's no two
edges connecting a red node ok so that's
independent set maximal is that I can't
add anything to it and how do you
compute this thing ok I so what I'd like
actually is here is my input it's the
graph I'd like to make queries to the
graphing and then and what the local
computation algorithm should do is given
some node V as tell me or some known you
tell me is you in the maximal
independent set ok and I'd like to do
this without looking at the whole graph
ok so this seems pretty trivial because
here's what we could do I'm
call this the lazy greedy algorithm
because it's very lazy I'm going to ask
is node you in the maximal independent
set and you know you it is always in
some maximal independent so actually
before we get to this let's do it and
even lazier thing let me just always say
yes right you always always in some
maximal independent set what's the
problem with that the question isn't
whether you is in some maximal
independent set it's in a particular
output whether you is in a maximal
independent set so the problem is that
if I ask queries about other nodes I
need to remain consistent okay so then
all right still no problem because what
I'll do is I'll just keep track of the
answers I've given so far okay so I'll
ask if node you in the maximum maximal
independent set and the answer will be
if the neighbors of you have not yet
been put in the maximal independent set
I'll put it there okay and then I'll
just remember all the choices I made and
I'm done all right well the requirements
for this are I need order d dynes per
query because I have to look at all my
neighbors and we said that the degree
was bounded by D and I need order and
space because I need to remember every
previous career I made and you know as
this thing runs it's going to take some
time all right so other problems with
this the space is large also the answer
depends on the query order you know if
you ask me about no of you before node V
I might give you a different answer well
so I have to I have to remember all my
past choices and it cannot allow
simultaneous and non interacting copies
of these local computation algorithms to
like work be working out there in the
cloud okay so I'm not even talking about
parallel algorithms I'm talking about
two copies of the algorithms that aren't
talking to each other and not helping
each other either but I running out
there yeah I'm just slightly confused
about what the input is when the input
be also labeling of which nodes are in
the independence center you know the
input is it's just a graph yep you're
not seeing the whole graph at one so
when you query don't you get
and also see was it said no no I decide
that but I have to decide that in a way
that's consistent with like if a copy of
me had been deciding about my neighbor I
need to be you know but the copy of me
like I don't want to communicate all
possible graphs and I also need you know
I haven't seen the whole Greta I don't
even know the whole input so someone
gave a separate query sequence that
query that you don't know about that
they created neighbors of them know that
you said was in the independence that
they better all be out that's right and
so that's what's the problem with this
solution so does this mean that you have
to be oblivious to query order yes yes
that's what well that's what we'd like
if you have that that's what we'd like
okay so that's what the model would like
but you know so that's a problem with
this type of yeah the algorithm you're
trying to emulate the hidden one this is
non-deterministic
hey let me get to what they heard i'm
going to try to in this talk I'm going
to emulate several algorithms finding
those produced anything as long as it
remains consistent that's right
that's right so I'd like to turn it into
a function that I want to compute as you
as you're pointing out that in some
sense this is not good and so let's make
it just a function that I want to
compute in some way okay and I wanted a
function that i can compute quickly all
right so we'd like to avoid these
problems so let me just say you know in
nature it seems like people have avoided
these problems so here's an example at
well I you know I i think this slide was
meant to say maximal independent set
although it's a toy example it's not
really a toy example because it's an
important tool in distributed computing
it's a used in optimization it's um you
know this is a picture of drosophila
brain development and somehow these
cells can figure out there's they try to
elect leader cells and these cells can
figure out who's going to be a leader
cell in such a way that the neighbors
aren't choose choosing to be leader
cells so they seem to be doing some sort
of maximal independent set computation
or at least that's what this effect at
all paper seems to be claiming so I you
know if somebody can do it okay so
similar or some in defensive this large
I mean
I mean I would refer you to the paper
but they are claiming maximal
independent set but I maybe it's just
large I and maybe it's not that
independent but I don't know okay so the
main camp I hope what we've agreed on
until now the main challenge is to be
consistent okay well this has come up
before um oh it was okay so let me go
back to the model now that we have this
example here we what's interesting so
the main challenges it to be consistent
with a particular solution so that was
what sort of missing from the previous
slide of the model here we have an input
X of size n there's a set of legal
solutions y 1 through why yes you got to
pick one and stay consistent with that
solution ok so this local computation
algorithm has to decide to give you
access to some y sub K and it should
answer any sequence of queries with most
t of n time per query and use it most s
event space and hopefully these guys r
sub linear and it should also be correct
for all queries with probability 1 minus
delta oven so there's some these are
going to be randomized there might be
some probability that everybody messes
up but you'd like to be able to control
this and make this small like we're
hoping the delta be something like 1
over N or 1 over some yet something
really really small okay so okay so this
is kind of a picture that's the input
that's the local computation algorithm
it's thinking of some output there are s
different options it flips a random
string and uses that to pick the option
that it's going to answer according to
and then once it picks that random
string it's always going to output
according to the same solution okay so
it's always it it's always going to give
you answers according to a single YK
okay so that's sort of the idea of the
model all right okay
okay and we talked about this um okay I
guess the one point here is that the
idea is if you think of it as swarms of
these lca's out there in the cloud then
you think of them initially sharing some
random string hopefully not too large
and afterwards they can compute
independently they don't need to talk to
each other so now okay so now what I
want to talk about is how do we design
these things okay so I want to just sort
of survey a bunch of techniques that
people have used in and I'll use and
they've applied them all to maximal
independent set so I can sort of sort of
take you through it most of the most of
the ideas have been applied to maximal
independent set one way or another so
we'll just keep going there okay so the
hope is you're going to try to find some
like normal maximal independent set
algorithm it's not local at all and
let's call that algorithm a and you're
going to hope that A's answer depends on
only a few inputs to determine how it
answers for V and if you had such a
thing then you would just simulate this
special algorithm that only looks at a
few inputs simulate aids behavior for v
okay so that would be the hope but how
do you get such an A which only looks at
a few inputs that's sort of like that's
our whole goal yeah no no pre-processing
I ok so the hope is somehow this a looks
only the neighborhood around me that
would be great well idea number one is
sort of to use what's known in
distributed algorithms and which is a
lot actually okay so it turns out and
this is an observation of parnis and Ron
but it actually is very powerful
observation and is used in a lot of in a
lot of the design of local computation
algorithms and as well as a lot of
property testers which is if there's AK
round distributed algorithm for maximal
independent set then these output only
depends on the input wait let's make the
picture you've got a que round algorithm
now this is the local distributed model
okay so the local distributed model is
not to be confused with this the local
sequential model because in the local
distributed model they're actually you
know it's a bunch of processors working
together okay so it's it's not
sequential but in the local distributed
model they
has been a lot of great work done in the
last 15 years I mean it's a lot of great
work done since it's a since it started
but in the last 15 years there's been a
ton of problems that can be solved in
the local distributed model and we can
take advantage of their successes and
kind of bring them over to our world
okay so that's kind of the idea but why
why does it help to have a local
distributed algorithm well if you have a
que round distributed algorithm and just
for those of you that are not used to
distributed algorithms let me tell you
something about that that it took me a
little bit to understand okay so when
you have a distributed algorithm the
input is actually the graph that you're
trying to compute the parameter for okay
so so that I mean the the communication
graph in the input graph are identical
so that's something that may not be
obvious if you haven't seen distributed
algorithms before and so if you're
computing a maximal independent set on a
graph it's exactly the communication
graph that you're computing it for so
that's one thing and now if you have a
local k local algorithm it means you run
in k rounds that's it okay so that means
that my input can only depend on on
input bits and sorry my output can only
depend on inputs that were in a que ball
around me ok so because I can only get
messages from K steps away from me you
know in k rounds I can only get messages
that were K steps away from me that's
the most i can see i can only be
influenced by the cable okay well we
assumed an upper bound d on the degree
so the size of my k radius ball is at
most D to the K okay so i can read this
whole yellow section indeed of the k
queries I'm I'm now in a sequential
model ok so I'm going to look at all
these inputs indeed of the Kate I
simulate what the distributed algorithm
would have done and figure out what the
answer would be for me according to the
distributed algorithm but now I'm just
simulating indie to the K sequential
time okay so it's a que round
distributed algorithm i'm simulating all
the work that it would have done indeed
of the kc quen chill time so it's an
exponent
blow up but we were assuming d as a
constant and we were assuming K is a
constant so so that's why it's okay now
that's the beauty of these local
algorithms is K is a constant okay so
that's um so k is not so bad all right
are we following here yeah questions the
individual notes have names and if the
names came from a totally ordered set
you have a trivial algorithm just look
at any node and see if its name was
bigger than the names of all of its
neighbors that's I thanks okay uh that's
actually um maybe i'll use the board for
that in a minute so give me a minute
it's great it's a great question okay
just a line and labels are sorted along
the line so this algorithm
so maybe am I allowed to use okay
remember somebody wants to do that it
exceeds remember hey who go and a
and after he did that he said well
you'll remember me for a long time and
sure enough we did yeah okay so yet so I
think this is the example yes I so you
could have like 12 a thousand but so but
you need to know the parody of how many
people came before you and if one edge
was missing that could change the whole
parody and so you really so it doesn't
solve the problem but it's a good it's a
good thought hold that thought we could
also have started by this also delivers
you could have two paths of opposite
parity to a local minimum so yeah I
think not like there's one parody for
every node but there's a I mean even
that's bad enough because you would have
to check that each edges there but the
two paths case is also bad so we'll get
to this okay but um but right now we're
just using distributed algorithms first
and so local local distributed
algorithms are constant round there's a
ton of them there's been great work and
distributed algorithms finding local
algorithms they can do a lot of things
they can do they can do packing problems
covering problems they can do a a well
so in that's the kind of most general
case but you know they can do things
like set cover they can do vertex cover
they can do you know they have a really
very powerful algorithms in the local
model matching or like large matching
and so that's really good news for local
computation algorithms because now we
have like one you know we can just
basically import all the results from
local distributed algorithms and
construct a whole bunch of local
computation algorithms okay so that's
technique one and you know so we can
talk about what does this tell us for
maximal independent set well if you just
took this is not actually local because
it's d login instead of just but if you
just took luby's algorithm for maximal
independent set there's Lou be right
there and you you would get something
that's not quite what you wanted it
because you get this to to the D lagdi
login up in this up here and
not good because it's not sublinear so
that doesn't seem like it works but okay
but I'm going to tell you later with
additional ideas and different
algorithms we can do a lot better
including taking the idea from this
algorithm and using it to do other
things which I'll mention in the next
slide ok so I just want to say there's
been a whole slew of work in this
direction improving maximal independent
set based on flat-out distributed
algorithms ok and I should also mention
that day in this recent paper of
ghaffari and also some work a barenboim
at all I actually ideas from local
computation algorithms have been used to
improve local distributed algorithms so
there's been sort of an interplay in the
two communities over the last few years
ok so idea number two is kind of like
distributed algorithms but it's to use
distributed algorithms plus another idea
ok and here we'd like to use distributed
algorithms to kind of break up the graph
into really small pieces and then we can
do something sequential on what's left
ok so here's an example for mis we're
going to basically run d round order d
rounds of a variant of luby's algorithm
ok so just what is luby's algorithm do
it says ok I'm going to mark myself with
probability 1 over twice my degree and
then I'm going to look around at my
neighbors and see did any of them mark
themselves and if none of them worked
themselves then I put myself in the
maximal independent set ok so that's
luby's algorithm and if any of them did
mark themselves then we all unmarked
ourselves ok so that's the algorithm and
ok you need to run this thing d log n
times in order to analyze it but what if
you just run it order d rounds what
happens then ok so you're going to get
rid of a large fraction of the notes but
better than that it's not just that the
number of nodes you get get rid of is
going to be is going to be mostly is
going to be a large fraction of the
notes you're also going to get rid of
them in a nice pattern ok so what's
going to happen is what remains our
small connect
components so you're actually going to
break up the graph into small tiny
pieces that are see polly logarithmic in
length and then you know in phase two
you can go through these little pieces
and do some kind of brute force
sequential algorithm okay so that's the
idea here and it did I guess to satisfy
your previous condition you need all the
copies of the cell guru to using the
same random bits that's right that's
right a lot of them will fail right so
there we're going to use Luggin ways
independence and that's going to save us
a lot of random bits that we have to
share okay and that's going to be enough
because no no section looks at more than
that so so what this local computation
algorithm would do would be to first
simulate these local view of the
distributed algorithm running order d
rounds d rounds of luby's algorithm and
then you know once we're done with that
we have to figure out who my connected
component is that remains so I'm gonna
like I'm gonna figure out locally what
the distributed algorithm would say
about me am I in the maximal independent
set or should i or am I still alive and
I would then check my neighbors and I
would keep checking my neighbors
neighbors five minutes good okay and
that's what I would do okay so um this
idea you know was further used by other
others in this whole framework ok so
then also you have to argue that what's
you know that you don't have to go that
far to figure out who's in your life
connected component and you argue that
based on it on an argument that's very
similar to Beck's not very similar it's
almost identical to Beck's algorithm
Beck's argument about a analyzing the
lavas local Emma algorithm okay so so if
you use that then you can you can get
this bound on the sizes of the of the
components and this kind of idea this
sort of framework was used as well in
distributed algorithms okay all right so
another idea in my two remaining minutes
is a dicks idea which is to simulate the
greedy approach okay so if you like
simulate sequential greedy as dick
suggested then you would run through the
okay this is now the sequential
algorithm I just want to be we should
all agree what this sequential algorithm
does and then see how we can simulate it
the sequential algorithm would run
through the nodes in some order maybe
one through I mean maybe alphabetical
order or some other order and now what
we'll do is we'll put our node V into
the maximal independent set if none of
its neighbors have been put in the
maximal independent set yet okay and
that's the algorithm dick was suggesting
and now the LCA is supposed to compute
what would greedy do on you unknown you
okay so I'm given a queer you is you in
the maximal independent set I have to
figure out what greedy it put me in or
not so I have to look at all my lower
numbered neighbors according to this I
have to look at all my lowered numbered
neighbors and see if greedy put them in
the maximal independent set because if
any of them are put in the maximal
independent set I can't go in okay and
in order to figure out if they were put
in the maximal independent set I have to
look at their lower numbered neighbors
to figure out if greedy had previously
placed them in the maximal independent
this could go on forever and in this
example basically to figure out if these
guys in the maximal independent set I
have to look at his neighbor to figure
out if he's in the maximal independent
set I have to look at his neighbor and
so on all the way down the line so this
is a really bad ordering for that
particular graph okay so but the thing
to notice is it's independent of you
know I don't have to look at anything
that's numbered higher than me in the
ordering because I know that greedy
hasn't put them in the maximal
independent set because it hasn't even
looked at it yet greedy goes through
them in a specific order okay so the
problem with greedy is in general the
dependency chains of this kind of
reasoning could be really long but if
the order were picked randomly then you
can show in New in and onyx show this in
a slightly different context but not
very different context that you can show
that the order that the dependency
chains are not going to be long okay and
so you can show that these dependencies
chains are short if the if the ranks of
the if the names of the elements were
chosen randomly and you can show it
using some gult and Watson branching
process ideas and
me and in fact that's another technique
that people use to construct local
algorithms okay and you've already asked
me about the space requirements for the
random bits and we'll use K wise
independence okay now there's a bunch of
works improving M is using all kinds of
ideas using better distributed protocols
better I don't even have time to get
into this but I okay so let's just just
say that the main open question it's
gotten all the way down to Kwazii
polynomial in the degree and the big
question is can you get polynomial
indeed dependence but right now the
dependence on n can be either be log
star n and exponential in the degree or
log cubed and and Kwazii Polly in the
degree so that seems to be the best okay
I should mention that many other
problems have been looked at approximate
maximum matching so it's not maximum but
getting close to a large matching rate
certain kinds of scheduling problems
hyper graph coloring k CNF local
computation mechanism design has been
looked at and various online algorithms
such as load balancing with balls and
bins and in all these cases you get poly
log query and space complexity here's
something I'm not going to talk about
but let me let me just say the problem
suppose you're given a graph and you'd
like to identify the edges that are in
some spanning tree okay turns out this
problem in general you know is has an
Omega n lower bound but you can do
things like find sparse spanning trees
on some graphs okay so I so it's I think
it's a good set of open questions we
don't know how to do it in general but
we can find sparse spanning trees that
kind of connect a graph don't have more
than 1 plus epsilon and edges okay so
they have their more than trees they do
have extra edges but they don't have
more than epsilon and extra edges over a
tree okay and so you'd like to do this
there's a lower bound of root end for
general graphs for special case graphs
like hyper finite graphs and they and
other kind of really non expanding graph
then you can get
stint in terms of N and Kwazii poly in
terms of the degree and for expand
certain kinds of very nice expanding
graphs you can get Rudin kind of near
the lower bound so I think I'm past my
time so let me just say as far as the
model I just want to say that some work
has been how many minutes drive is 0
right negative one okay so so a so I
just want to say as far as the model the
in our model we allowed sort of random
access to the input we didn't require
that as you would in distributed
algorithms that you can only do
essentially search it like you can start
at node you and you can look at the
neighbors the neighbors of the neighbors
and so on the question is do non-local
probes help for graphs for graphs for at
least some large nice graph class of
graph problems the answer is no the
non-local probes don't actually help but
I don't know if this is true for all
graph problems and this is really only a
result for graft and I guess if you like
the picture one takeaway message I hope
that you get from this is that you can
kind of kill several birds with one
stone meaning that the space the
simultaneous consistency in the history
independent all seem related so like you
fix one you fix them all in some sense I
don't have a theorem that says they
should be related but but it seems
somehow that that's what happened
there's a lot of open questions here I
and I think the most interesting open
question is new problems you can always
improve on the old problems and get an
even better maximal independent set
result but I think how do how to apply
this kind of model to new problems is
the most exciting thing
I do have one common in the original mis
paper one of the algorithms was to pick
a random label for each of notes and
then just do the maximal independent set
according to which one is lowest among
its neighbors attitude and so that's
very similar to what you actually yeah
and some in some of those okay so there
are there a lot of maximal independent
sets that have been they so did your
algorithm and variance of is like whoa
half the internet and all of them have
been analyzed in those in that list of
things but I didn't have time to talk
about it yeah you're in vegetable